hi this is a science hangout from a
science mission
I am Sadashiva Pyle today we are
fortunate to have a doctor
Aditi das assistant professor in the
department of comparative Biosciences at
the University of Illinois
urbana-champaign with us she has done
extensive work on some of the
interesting stuff in the biology she has
won several awards I renamed couple of
them because I can go on forever if I
talk about them
so in 2017 she won the best paper award
from Department of Biochemistry and 2016
she was the United member of the
editorial board of chem select chem pups
Society Europe 2014 to 2016 she has the
lightning talk liquid maps meetings San
Diego and of course Lexie has won
several more of these several awards and
she's also authored several publications
more than 35 publications she's in the
review board of several journals and she
is one of the accomplished researcher in
her field welcome dr. Gus to hand out
much for this opportunity to give an
talk on my research I'm very excited to
share this with you can you tell us
about yourself
a little bit about your background
education extra so I did my bachelor's
at st. Stephen's College Delhi then I
went on to do my masters from IIT Kanpur
in chemistry both in chemistry after
that I was briefly my dinelli followed
by my PhD at Princeton University and
after Princeton University I came to
urbana-champaign to do my postdoctoral
work which was in collaboration with the
Northwestern and Technology Center and
Beckman Institute and after that I
joined the faculty position here so this
is so my training primary
training has been in India and then rest
of the training in the US okay like tell
us about like since yeah is very brief
research carrier of course the clearance
into almost a decade or more can you
tell us about your mentors or the road
models which supported you in your
career
so my first mentor was my professor in
my masters during in IIT Kanpur doctor
Saab Rosati shocker
he was he always trained me to have a
very open minded approach and think out
of the box and he also told me if a
question cannot be answered answered
this way there are many other ways you
can approach a question and try to
answer it and I think from him I have
become a I feel I've become a moral
go-getter with scientific questions and
I know them different ways of looking at
it one question and my PhD mentor gave
me a lot of space to explore what I want
to do and that training helps me a lot
so professor Michael Hecht at Princeton
he would always encourage and he would
always tell us what do we want to do and
that made us think and progress in our
project and my my postdoc mentor
professor Steve sly guard he was like
motivation for the science
he was a very versatile scientist and he
has taught me to be extremely versatile
so there my creamy primary mentors and I
and then I look up to Linus Pauling okay
and I know you are a busy scientist and
other than research you have any other
hobbies or other things you do yes I was
I am a musician I'm a classical list and
trained for a long time with mr. Mitra
Guha who's right now Padma Shri award
winner and I have also been in Norway as
a musician in the Rick's concert in
music group so so much been my interest
which is
classical music folk music can I move
oculist okay and coming back to the
research part like can you talk about
little bit about your lab and the
students their projects little bit about
pay so my battery right now I have seven
grad students and my lab focuses on
lipid metabolism by cytochrome p450 to
make anti inflammatory molecules so we
are a so I imbibe the same principles
that I learned from my PhD and postdoc
advisor so my students get their own
project and then they have they also are
a la you know they are also encouraged
to come up with their own project in the
third fourth year so that they are
innovative they can bring their thoughts
so that's how I run my lab at
comparative Biosciences and yes so and I
have graduated three PhD students and
yeah that's it
okay so I'm talk about the novel
anti-inflammatory bioactive lipids which
are coming from the SIP epoxidized
pathway and I thought I want to first
talk about why I'd this implies this
important so if you think of all the
different diseases people study the
different diseases separately but what
is common between vascular disease as
I'm or Parkinson disease pain arthritis
so the most common theme and all these
diseases is inflammation so inflammation
is a common unifying confident in many
of these chronic disease conditions so
the the idea of my lab is then if we can
find molecules that can control
inflammation not only reduce it but even
find unit then we can have an integrated
approach towards trying to tackle all
these different disease states so if you
think of acute inflammatory response you
do need that you do need information
because information is a natural and a
protective response to specific in cells
such as injury or infection for instance
if you think of what is really
inflammation so like vasoconstriction
baicao dilation and vascular
permeability chemotaxis addition these
are all part of the acute inflammatory
response which is very important but the
problem arises when this inflammation
does not resolve so what I mean by that
is when the acute inflammation becomes
chronic inflammation and this chronic
inflammation is what we are trying to
tackle is what we are trying to reduce
so this is a concept popularized by
Professor Charlie Sirhan from Harvard
and that is the concept of inflammation
resolution what is inflammation
resolution the information resolution is
an active process in which you resolve
the acute inflammation by removal
restoration regeneration remission and
relief and what molecules do these
inflammation resolution these are the
novel lipid mediated
so our interest is to look for many
different novel lipid mediators with
tact and audience in your order to
resolve the inflammation and one of the
therapeutic implication could be to
increase the levels of these molecules
or make derivatives of these molecules
which can result inflammation so these
are the two major goals so how are these
lipid mediators generated what are these
like lipid mediators what do they
mediate so these lipid mediators they
all come from the omega-3 and omega-6
fatty acids that you consume so you
always hear the papers that make
actually I guess six fatty acids are
good for your health you should have DHA
supplements this is gonna reduce
depression it's going to do this this
gonna be good for a cardiovascular
health is good reduce cancer Neronian t
diseases so the question that comes to
mind is how can one class of Ceuta khals
or food item which is the omega-3 fatty
acids can do so many different effects
this implies that there is a common
biochemical pathway where the omega-3
fatty acids are getting converted into
these lipid mediators which in turn are
controlling all these different diseases
and as I mentioned before these diseases
have an inflammatory component so these
lipid mean mediators controlling the
information and that's why they can
affect all these different diseases pull
into the more scientific understanding
of what happens when you consume omega-3
and omega-6 fatty acids so make a 6
fatty acid an omega-3 fatty acid when
they are consumed they start getting
incorporated into the lipid bilayer as
shown here so we are essentially what we
eat so a person can change his body's
lipid composition by consuming more
omega-3 fatty acid over time this
omega-3 fatty acids are stored in the
membrane until there is an injury or
insert or trauma
induces phospholipase a and
phospholipase a releases these fatty
acids from the membrane so this is the
omega-6 fatty acid and the omega-3 fatty
acids classified into epa and DHA so
what happens to the epa and DHA further
there are three pathways that these
molecules go through and these molecules
now then can control the in crematory
response so the first pathway is called
cyclooxygenase pathway and all of you
are familiar with this pathway because
this is the pathway that is blocked by
all the NSAIDs such as morphine leave
Advil aspirin everything so what is this
pathway do is it makes prostaglandins
so it takes omega-6 fatty acids make
some agus its prostaglandins it takes so
megha three fatty acids and makes
omega-3 prostaglandins and its are
cyclic fatty acids and they are they are
pro-inflammatory in nature the silicon
pathway called the leap onyx pathway
synthesizes leukotrienes
and these molecules are also pro
inflammatory the leaf action is pathway
is the target for a lot of anti asthma
drugs and therefore this is also a
targetable pathway so why would Cyclops
chain is and lipoxygenase are targetable
pathway to reduce the inflammation in
the body there's another pathway in the
body a little bit neglected pathway
because this pathway you cannot really
block because it makes these molecules
which are all anti-inflammatory and
vasodilatory so they're beneficial for
your health essentially so what is
pathway does is it takes omega-6 and
omega-3 fatty acids and converts them to
these corresponding omega-6 and omega-3
POC sides
unlike the [ __ ] in the LOX pathway the
e path pathway is a completely anti
inflammatory pathway so this is this
anti inflammatory pathway and epochs are
cytochrome p450 epochs genesis so what
is cytochrome p450 oxidases and that's
what i'm going to further talk about Lee
the outline of my talk will be talking
about the biochemical mechanism of the
cytochrome p450 oxidases focusing on
their ability to metabolize lipids and
forming oxides as well as showing how
certain carry oxygen actually mediate
their effect from by the through the
cytochrome p450 fox news and then i'm
going to talk about the discovery of
novel anti-inflammatory lipid
metabolites and then how do they affect
pain
multiple sclerosis and big big little
neuro information and I although I'm not
going to talking details about these but
these are the ongoing studies so first
let me talk about the biochemical
mechanism of the cytochrome p450
oxidases with respect to their ability
to metabolize lipids if you think of
human cytochrome p450 it would surprise
to know how many of these are in your
body there are 57 human cytochrome p450s
there are few which are orphan and
especially the ones in the brain people
think of cytochrome p450 as drug
metabolizing enzymes but they have
molecule functions functions that are
performed by cytochrome p450 are drug
metabolism / you know biotech metabolism
secondly they're involved in steroid
synthesis and that is a very regulated
process and thirdly they are involved in
fatty acid metabolism and that is the
enzyme class that I'm talking about so
we focus in our lab on cardiovascular
cytochrome p450 that are also extra
hepatic so these cardiovascular
cytochrome p450 a to j2 to c 8 + 2 c 9
so this 2j2 protein is highly expressed
in the cardiac myocytes
in humans the function of this enzyme by
da Rosalyn was shown to convert omega-3
and omega-6 fatty acids into epoxide
armed donek acid the tip to Jay to
converse this to all the rejoice verse
of this
bauxite so it forms one two three four
into isomers these are called epoxy I
Casas try Noack acids are also known as
needs if you can see this enzyme is
highly expressed in the heart muscle
tissue as well as in the cardiovascular
system the relative mRNA levels are very
high so if you think of the white as a
human cardiomyocytes then the the dark
grave the human heart so in the
hello I'll ask him
mercenaire function is it lowers blood
pressure the second thing it does is
prevents post ischemia beautiful.i with
mia and then is also implicated in
cardiovascular health celebrate vascular
health such as stroke so what I mean by
that is these epoxides are very
important reducing hypertension and
therefore there are many drugs that
target this pathway for reduction of
hypertension also if there are drugs
that we interfere with these enzymes and
it's production of the epoxies then
those draw those drugs could be
cardiotoxic too so the next one is we
are going to talk about this to you too
and our studies with this protein j2 and
put this into this nano discs what now
discard they are like sushi like
molecules where the where you can think
of the analogy as the lipids are the
rice the fish in the middle is the
membrane protein and the seaweed is the
membrane scaffold protein so this is a
way to stabilize membrane protein so
that you can get very good quality by
physical data from this and understand
the protein in a more native-like form
express cytochrome p450 2j2 in e.coli
we also expressed its redox partner con
site from people 50 reductase in coli as
well and incorporate them into nano
discs and challenge them with these
different fatty acids are in tonic acid
linoleic acid i person to know i casted
in toka serve hexanoic acid and we were
able to make the ets
as well as we were me able to meet make
the heats which are the hydroxy and then
we detect all of these molecules using
an LC ms/ms method that you also develop
in the lab so what we were able to show
in this paper was published in
biochemistry was that the arachidonic
acid metabolism is high and but when we
have the other fatty acids then they
have a tendency to inhibit arachidonic
acid metabolism so this shows the direct
metabolism rate which
very comparable to each other and they
do make it in a very slow turnover rate
and that's important because we don't
these molecules control heart rate and
we don't want to make a lot of these
molecules so they're made in a slow
quantity or amounts we found that DHA
actually inhibits tharok daanyik acid
metabolism and is a preferred substrate
for this enzyme so what I mean by that
is as I increasing amount of DHA the
arachidonic acid metabolism goes down
and DHA instead gets metabolized so if
he had an DeBaun omega-3 omega-6 fatty
acid and DHA would have been a preferred
substrate but because the Western diet
is more omega-6 fatty acid then it's
overwhelming amount of arachidonic acid
so do check cannot inhibit in that case
so to further show these all these fatty
acids are very similar structurally then
why are they like why are they binding
indifferently to the active site so we
showed we did this molecular modeling
with a mastercards group and oh that in
case of DHA DHA is interacting with
three residues in the active site of
this protein which is 309 318 arginine
321 and serine 493 and if we mutate out
two of these residues then this
selective preference of DHA for this
protein goes away and be and behave
exactly similar to our chronic acid
binding to the protein so here we show
that we make a double mutant where DHA
firstly inhibits in the wild-type 31%
and then the inhibition of DHA goes away
so those residues are critical for
giving DHA selectivity towards finding
this protein so after we have learned
that we were very interested in how
carry toxic drugs bind to this protein
and change this fatty acid metabolism
and we focused in doxorubicin so there
was a paper which caught our attention
that was from John supers group in
his paper said that sip 2j2
overexpression protects against
doxorubicin damage doxorubicin is a very
popular anti-cancer drug and it's also
very cardiotoxic there has been many
ways that people have tried to get
around this cardio toxicity but
understanding it's complete mechanism is
very important the doctors can do in the
markers is here is can produce reactive
oxygen species and that's what people
think is the main or main mechanism by
which doxorubicin is toxic where our
hypothesis which is I call it the
alternative hypothesis is in addition to
producing reactive oxygen species
doxorubicin also inhibits 2j2 and
decreases therefore that leads to
decrease in cardioprotective epoxides so
with this hypothesis in mind we went
ahead and did some other experiments
where we took two j2 and saw how the
doxorubicin can inhibit the metabolism
of fatty acids by 2g - so doxorubicin
has these tendency that this bond falls
off and it forms this molecule called 78
oxygens it is very well known that
doxorubicin
has a prolong cardio toxicity means even
after doxorubicin dosage have been
stopped then also the patients can have
cardio toxicity so this implies that
doxorubicin forms some metabolites that
stays around in the membranes of the
cardiovascular system that can further
cause cardio toxicity so with that goal
in mind he wanted to figure out what
really happens to the cox river seine
what does it do to the primary cardiac
cytochrome p450 so we first showed that
doxorubicin inhibits 2j2 and inhibits
quite a lot then we also showed that the
78 ox which is formed as a metabolite
from doxorubicin also inhibits 2j2
but not completely
and if I take a 50/50 percent ratio of
70 a dachsund doxorubicin then I get an
intermediate inhibition so the first
studies to us to show that doxorubicin
and his primary mental metabolite 7 da
dogs they inhibited 2j2 mediated
arachidonic acid metabolism what was
another thing that we observed which was
interesting was that the religio
selectivity changed so what i mean by
that is that I told you before that
there are four different video isomers
being formed that's 5 6 8 9 11 12 and 14
15 18 but doxorubicin changes the ratio
of these ETS and that could be hardened
because these eating's the different
have different functions with respect to
their cardio protection so if you are
changing the levels then and the like
video isomer ratio then we are changing
the character city potential of the drug
you know in collaboration with a masters
cautious group it is done by xavier
baden the 7 da docks and arab donek acid
can simultaneously in the active sites
so here I'm showing this is the product
and this arachidonic acid now in tonic
acid cannot bind to this original way so
now it's binding in a different way and
producing a change in the regio
selectivity so we and and we showed that
70 a dogs can bind to the active site
and modulate the regio selectivity of
arachidonic acid metabolism and this is
very interesting and physiologically
important as well now if this is true
that 70 a dogs can change the regio
isomer ratio then maybe we can show that
when doxorubicin analogues which are
less toxic that this does not happen
those
- dr. Simpson Alex five immune or Donna
Robeson or shortened form is five IDN
and Zhou reversing which is the RN both
of these drugs were obtained from
National Cancer Institute's and we are
very thankful for giving us the drugs
for the studies so we were able to show
that five Donna Robeson was as
inhibitory as doxorubicin for instance
there is a lot of inhibition as you can
see while in the other hand czar abuse
in which has a large group in this this
part of the molecule is less inhibitory
then as orbison but in both cases like
both v ID onions are abuse in the change
in the regis regio isomers was not very
much so what I'm showing in the right
figure let me walk you through this is
that regio selectivity change and the
fold change
so with doxorubicin we get a change in
the region formation of the more of five
six EDT and less formation of fourteen
fifteen eighty while in a docks we get
more formation of five six ET les
formation of fourteen fifteen ET but
just notice that czar mucin and five IDN
do not change regio selectivity although
they hibbett molecules for giving us
support for the proposed mechanism that
doxorubicin gets converted to seventy
eight ox and the seventy eight ox then
binds to the active site changes the
regio isomer of RM donek acid metabolism
so this is the summary of this work
where i will just walk you through the
it is cytochrome p450 reductase the
redox partner of two j to converge
doxorubicin into 70 dogs which is the
product but this product the body gets
rid off very easily because more
hydrophobic so it's linger arms and then
buying to 2j2 shown in dark purple here
and then when to teh to bind sardonic
acid it not only reduces the like rate
of metabolism but it also changes the
reach isomer ratio for instance five six
going out which is sought to be cardio
toxic eight nine and these are more the
cardio protected ones in the side
p40 reductase cpr the reader that's fine
metabolic I rocks and $78 binds to 2j to
and alters the preffered site of
metabolism of arachidonic acid leading
to change in the ratio of the Rieger
isomer and this work was done by William
are not talked about and the epoxides
themselves while so ah
our viewer I mean your cannabis
generated sorry n-word is the Bible
McCann so keep t intimate area for many
assets like dried all synthetics or
making whiskey much and it has also been
approved for treatment of migraines and
epileptic seizures joint pain and
stiffness collectively are known as
phyto cannabinoids phyto means their
plan base cannot pronounce as production
of similar kind of molecules so when
scientists first cover heard the fight
then the next question was why does the
human body have so many receptors to
recognize plant fighter cannabinoids
there must be an endogenous molecules
very similar to fighter cannabinoids
that to the led to the discovery of an
animal in 1992 and to AG denied glycerol
in 1994 it which is direct from the word
ananda in sanskrit means happiness it
happen is giving molecule and it binds
to cannabinoid receptor one it's a
partial agonist so these molecules they
all both bind to cannabinoid receptors
and do a lot of functions and among them
are
Mottola tree and immunomodulatory
actions so where do these endo
cannabinoids come from that there is an
omega-6 endocannabinoids and these
omega-6 endocannabinoids as the name
suggests come from omega-6 fatty acid
and if you can see that this is a very
clever way that nature works there is
just an ethanol mite moiety here and
they have such different pharmacology
so the ananda might are derived from
organic acid and to our donna glycerol
is derived from mmm I'm Donna Cassie -
and these are the differences they have
in their modifications so an and amide
and two AG have been shown three
anticonvulsant psychotropic as well as
anti-inflammatory so with the increasing
consumption of omega-3 fatty acid the
question was do these form omega-3
endocannabinoids this of paper from
Alexander McCree an Isis group was the
leading expert in the field of this
endocannabinoids and different kinds of
drugs related to that their lab showed
that yes
DHA gets converted to DHEA very similar
to a nanda mine
you
a new anti inflammatory molecules so
this is the pathway again there are
these three enzymes the cyclooxygenase
the sign from p450 oxygenase and the
lipoxygenase pathway so what has been
shown by Larry Martin's group that
cyclooxygenase converts the anandamayi
into prostaglandin EA prostaglandin EA
has very different pharmacology from
prostaglandin just because it has this
part and then another group showed the
lipoxygenase is convert an animai to 12
peroxy ethanol amide and this is also
LICO trying with a different
pharmacology again so our group and
Natasha Schneider from Paul hollenberg
group have shown that anandamayi gets
converted by the cytochrome p450 to form
all rejoice swimmers off of ETS EA so
these are the ethanol of my deep oxide
dual functional molecules plus further
interested and after we published our
first paper which very we talked about
that a nano mind gets converted to ete
A's by cytochrome p450 we
[Music]
French ammonites gets metabolized by
cytochrome p450 to form omega-3
endocannabinoid epoxides so these are
very similar to these molecules except
that they are the omega-3 versions
they're also very similar to these
molecules but the fact that they have an
epoxide Vantage of these molecules is
they have thereby functional so they
have an epoxide group as well as an
ethanol amide group and that can make
them very interesting and this can go
through multiple different signaling
pathways so we are in order to study
these the we have to synthesize these
molecules and develop an LC ms/ms method
so these are all the reader isomers of
EPA also known as EQ EA and these are
the different 3d isomers of EDP which
are coming from DHA so there are DHA
base products so in order to synthesize
them we synthesized we added DHA we did
IMCP be a reaction and make the epoxides
and then we attend all amide couple them
to form the CDP EA and when we developed
a separation method where we looked at
their separations into this different
video isomers using some of the
standards from came on campus and and
then we were able to separate out all
these video isomers so this shows the
targeted lipid omics method that we used
are made to separate these molecules and
this shows how these fragments have
overlapping masses for instance 17 18 AQ
EA and 1415 eq EA has overlapping masses
as well as fragmentation pattern but
they have different solution time in the
LC so we use we use the ABC x 5500 Q
trap machine to do Li studies so we were
able to develop targeted epidemics
method to look at all the different
rejoice o MERS of the epoxide
so our first question are this epoxide
body or are they just a figment of
imagination so there is a lot of things
that people can do in an in vitro cell
in cellular system that is make new
molecules and by using different enzyme
systems but artists found endogenously
in the body was the first question in
our mind so we went and did tissue
analysis of rat and especially of the
rat brain and we also did all the organs
we also actually first discovered these
molecules in pig brain and then we also
found this in human bodies so what we
did here was we took the in the in the
rat brain we found that these molecules
are actually expressed or found at equal
levels to an and amide which is the most
studied endocannabinoid and that implied
that meaning these molecules are doing
something in the brain and then you also
found 1718 equally less amount in 1928
EPA but they were also there we also
were able to find these molecules a lot
in the different organs especially in
the kidneys so kidney has lot of the
cytochrome p450s and therefore it made a
lot of these epoxides and kidney is also
involved in controlling hypertension and
as ice' mentioned before these molecules
are implicated in reduction of
hypertension we were able to also see
these in the human pooled human plasma
set that we analyzed in good enough
quantities so next we were interested in
who formed these metabolites so omega-3
in to cannabinoid metabolism we were
interested is to j2 that synthesizes it
is that their enzymes in the brain
microsomes or are these activated
microglia which are synthesizing that so
similar to the approach that we took
before we took to j2 and CPR put this
into a narrow disc and then we
challenged that with DHEA and NADPH so
that then we sure that this we're
getting metabolized and the terminal and
the cannabinoid was forming the maximum
amount of these epoxides
and then we we made a ratio of how many
they're forming so it's seen the
terminal was 76.5% and then 8.7 parts
and five and three person so they are
less and less but the terminal one is
the most predominant one and this shows
here at the rate of metabolism which is
faster than arachidonic acid similar to
and I'm the mite metabolism next we
showed similar study with EB EA like as
the parent compound and similar to DHEA
the terminal epoxides were formed the
highest quantity here again the rates
were similar to that of the DHEA but in
the pic and the rat brain Microsoft them
more cytochrome p450 into j2 so does the
brain have the enzymes or the capacity
to metabolize these molecules and they
do so we made with very standard method
of making brain microsomes we caught
some brains and we made microsomes
and we were able to show that both epa
and DHA ever getting metabolized and
producing similar ratios as we were
seeing with the purified enzyme so one
of the important thing is to use and
activated microvia are where is the
production of these molecules coming
from because endocannabinoids are
implicated more for their
neuroprotection
and undulatory effects we wanted to see
if these are produced by microglia does
activated microglia convert them into
these epoxides so in order to do this
study we used bv to microglial cells
what our microglia microglia are
macrophages of the brain the function of
the microglia is to reduce the
information the brain and to take care
of it and and because they are the
macrophages they are usually not found
in the brain in large quantity all the
time but only in a diseased state most
of the diseases that you tinkoff which
which relates to the brain for instance
of Zimmer Parkinson multiple sclerosis
all these diseases are accompanied by a
lot of neuro inflammation and the
microglia gets activated in those cases
so we took APA and challenged it and
gave it to BB to microbial cells but
still activated microglia and again very
similar to the brain microsomes
and the purified enzyme we were able to
make all these metabolites so are these
metabolites really made or do they are
they already stored there's a different
way of making it so we used a simple
study where we had the metabolites
formed by the BB - activated micro Pia
and then we added an inhibitor called
ketoconazole which is an inhibitor of
cytochrome p450 and we were able to show
a decrease in the production of the of
the metabolites which showed that the
cytochrome p450s are involved in the
metabolism of the cpa and DHEA
in the microbial cells next question was
that these metabolites once they are
formed who degrades them because if they
are so good they might linger around in
the body for a long time and use all the
inflammation in the body but they are
taken care of by more downstream enzymes
so we looked at the metabolism by
soluble epoxide hydrolase what soluble
epoxide hydrolase do is it hydrolyzes
they oxide bond so soluble epoxide
hydrolase essentially converse these
epoxides into the hydroxylated form and
this is the rate of the formation of
these epoxides into the hydroxylated
form and that of the 19:20 EDP next we
look at another enzyme for fatty acid
amide hydrolase again as the name
suggests its function is to do an amide
hydrolysis which is it converts this
ethanol amide part into the fatty acids
so 1780 and then we also measure this
using rad for brain membranes which
highly express this protein that you are
able to show that these
get metabolized by fatty acid amide
hydrolysis this question was now that
what is the functional implication of
this Pro of these molecules so we find
these molecules they are formed by
cytochrome p450 they are degraded by
soluble epoxide hydrolase and far but
then what is their function what are
they doing in the body and the brain
first we wanted to look at their
functions with respect to their
endocannabinoid like property which is
binding cannabinoid receptor 1 & 2 what
are cannabinoid receptors can I have an
ion receptor is primarily thought to be
two major classes there are more
receptors which people think are there
there's still a lot of research going on
in those receptors so can have in our
receptor one is more mostly found in the
brain and is involved in the
psychotropic effect of cannabis and
similar molecules on the other hand
cannabinoid receptor 2 is found mostly
in the immune system and it's implicated
in anti-inflammatory action of
cannabinoids on the right you see here
is the distribution of the cannabinoid
receptors you can see cannabinoid
receptor one is a lot in the brain a lot
in the gut while the cannabinoid
receptor 2 is is all over the body there
was a recent paper in Nature Reviews
which said that CB 2 selective agonist
that is cannabinoid receptors selective
agonist are therapeutic a target for
pain management immune system modulation
without the overt activity of
cannabinoid receptor 1 so there was a
lot of interest in synthesizing
cannabinoid receptor 2 selective agonist
which will which will have all the
anti-inflammatory property but will not
cause a psychotropic effect so there was
some observation we made from a previous
work done by Schneider and hollenberg
that when Ananda mite is converted to
the epoxide this epoxide actually is
very selective cannabinoid receptor 2
agonist so if you notice on the right
here this shows radio ligand binding so
we are looking at the specific binding
of the CP 5 5 9 4 zeros is a strong
agonist of Kaname receptor
1 & 2 so here we see that with respect
to cannabinoid receptor 1 the N and
amide binds it much better than 5 6 EG
but 5 6 et binds cannabinoid receptor 2
more potently than cannabinoid receptor
1 so what this shows is there is a class
switching means that the anandam ID
which is more cannabinoid receptor 1
selective becomes a cannabinoid receptor
2 selective when cytochrome p450
converts and undermine into the epoxide
indicating that may be under an
inflammatory condition when the
cytochrome p450 levels goes up then they
convert these molecules into more anti
inflammatory molecules to attack the
information so in we also should be
we're not going to ask the question that
is this true for the omega-3
endocannabinoids so we took the omega-3
endocannabinoids and we were able to
show that that's true for the epa
epoxides
like why EPE a binds to cannabinoid
receptor 1 more than the cannabinoid
receptor 1 compared to the 1718 eqe a
but the cannabinoid receptor to the 7018
ukiyo-e a is shown in purple binds
better than EPA receptor class switching
and the Emam cannabinoid efox I'd show
cannabinoid receptor 2 preference but
there's just not one epoxide there are
many of them the DHEA epoxides there are
at least 6 of them fight for the EBA
back side there are 5 of them so we were
further interested like what is their
interaction with the different
cannabinoid receptors and we were able
to show that they now mind very
differently with all the different
receptors and like the CNR one response
for the different rejoice swimmer is
different see an R 2 response is
different for instance if I look at EPA
which has c NR it's binding to c NR 1
and 2 almost similarly but and so is the
890 q EA but then the 1459 q is
different this data is more dramatic
with that of the DHEA epoxides where we
show the DHEA which does not bind to
either of the cannabinoid receptor
- very odd indeed but one
you
[Music]
[Music]
so all CNS diseases they have activated
CLIA and these play a lot of key role
and potential therapeutic targets in
your pain
epilepsy neurogenetic diseases ALS
stroke is that you can think of so the
next question was that what is the
anti-inflammatory studies in microbial
cells and we were able to show that to
microbial cells and increase in the
il-10 production for both terminals and
finally we were able to show that the
video isomers are different from each
other and these are ongoing spans and
the last thing we want is the base or
activity of the endocannabinoid II oxide
that oxide light qualities in order to
do these studies we took bovine coronary
artery vasodilation studies where we
took a coronary artery chopped into
smaller pieces and we were able to take
this and measure the height of the
finally the bovine coronary artery
vasodilation studies showed that very
able to dilate the vessels very similar
to the parent compounds
lucky what we have shown is that
naturally-occurring Omega 300
cannabinoid bauxite are formed by the
zipper box in his pathway the
endocannabinoid fox eyes neither endo
cannabinoid like activity by binding to
preferring in all the read vice-versa
that you infamy recent il-10 production
also maintained activity target by
tweaking information so in summary I
talked about the biochemical mechanism
of this cytochrome p450 and then
discovery of the novel anti-inflammatory
lipid metabolites so I want to
acknowledge the people who did the work
the people who did the primary work with
respect to the mechanism is William
Arnold in the lab John abhi Roy she did
a lot of work on the molecule cancer in
a few small kaha and the work is right
now being written up josephine did
[Music]
protein involved in metabolism effect of
these endocannabinoids oxide
inflammation and share the presentation
double click on de yeah so it's a very
good at the end i don't know where the
noise was coming from yeah i think there
was some disturbances in between to like
I mean like you are cutting off in
between but it is ok I think overall it
sounded good I mean
like the presentation was very excellent
so do you know who was talking at the
end I think that end was quite like I
don't know if it looks good so like I
have couple of questions see if you
don't mind
yeah sure I think you need to unshare
again I think you are sharing is still
the Google rap okay okay this looks good
okay yeah no no no you can see you like
okay in the first first part - basically
like the mechanism part so yeah okay can
you buy drugs to modulate one or the
other forms like those sides yes I wish
so so I think the SIP 2j2 specific
inhibitors in this as well as the
crystal structure of the cytochrome p450
2j2 is in progress and right there is no
way to selectively
control the epoxide formation but people
are working towards it okay that's
that's interesting there's what like I
was thinking like if you can modulate
what you want like by changing some of
these recipes or whatever way targeted
way you can do it that would be really
useful and second second part is really
the second part leakage guiding because
I have a lot of brain related work it is
kind of very interesting in terms of in
terms of like pain and your inflammation
and all those things so how what is the
directions you are looking at basically
currently in that aspect
yes so we actually have multiple
directions in that project so we are
collaborating with multiple groups one
is these molecules we think are
implicated in pain so we are
collaborating with some pain groups to
see these molecules can be elevated and
that does that reduce pain by using
downstream inhibitors and then we are
also working in
multiple sclerosis group where we are
trying to see if these molecules have
any kind of you know repair mechanism
that they can do for instance you know
and repair the myelin sheath or maybe
prevent the myelin sheath from degrading
so and we have we are also looking at
neuro inflammation model like big linear
information model that if you feed them
DHA do you make more of these
metabolites so all these processes are
right now ongoing so therapeutic
implication could be making derivatives
of this molecules as drugs or increasing
the levels of this molecules by using
inhibitors do they have any effect on
blood-brain barrier or anything like
that like trying to connect the
blood-brain barrier so that is a good
question we haven't tested it but I
think across the blood-brain barrier
because there are lots of DHA uptake
with uptake proteins these are very much
likely shape because I saw a recent
paper I saw a recent paper on some of
the immune cells entering the brain I
don't know it is in our science mission
website recently I posted it I think I
should here today in basically so you
might want to have a look at it like
they do stop the blood-brain barrier and
all those things like different way of
entering the brain so since it is a
related to brain so I thought I will
bring that up and maybe it might be
useful for you yes yes no I would take a
look at that and again thank you so much
for your time this holiday you are
coming out and doing this we really
appreciate it and if anything something
interesting comes up let us know we'd be
happy to host you again thank you Happy
Thanksgiving
that same to you thanks